[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight here's a quick civics lesson
what's politics well politics is a
system that allows people who violently
disagree with each other to reach
compromise without shedding blood it's
worked well for a long time in this
country but when one side decides it is
no longer willing to compromise that
system breaks down without compromise
you no longer have politics instead you
have an especially fanatical form of
religious belief Isis for example is not
a political organization its leaders
reject accommodation of any kind its
leaders assume that everything they do
has the approval of a higher power they
are good people they know that they know
their beliefs are not simply correct
they're the only possible beliefs anyone
who disagrees with them is by definition
immoral so a system like that does not
allow for the possibility that good
people might be mistaken once in a while
or reach different conclusions sincerely
people with different opinions are again
by definition bad people in fact they
may not even be people at all they might
be subhuman they must be converted to
the faith or crushed and eliminated this
is not an American way of looking at the
world and yet suddenly it's everywhere
and unfortunately it now defines parts
of the modern Democratic Party Joe Biden
didn't know this Biden has been in
democratic politics all of his life but
he's taken the last couple of years off
he's been flying around the world
getting rich by giving high-priced
speeches by the time Biden decided he
wanted to run for president yet again
his party had changed completely but
nobody told him so he made the mistake
just the other day of saying this about
Mike Pence the fact of the matter is it
was followed on by a guy's a decent guy
our voice president who stood before
this group of allies and leaders and
said I'm here on behalf of President
Trump there was dead silence dead
silence
he's a decent guy Biden said of pence
that's an old-fashioned way to talk
that's how people in Washington
political Washington used to talk about
each other
was one way that they reminded
themselves the politics may be important
but it's not everything every political
opponent is also on some level anyway a
human being and a fellow American our
common humanity is stronger than our
political differences that was the
assumption that they had and have had at
least since the Civil War and by the way
it has to be the assumption that all of
us have if we're gonna live together in
the same country Cynthia Nixon disagrees
with this Nixon is a former actor she's
now a political extremists she spends a
lot of time on Twitter yelling at people
when she saw it Biden said about Penn
she was enraged Cynthia Nixon disagrees
with Mike Pence's views on gay rights
questions therefore she knows that pence
cannot be a decent person it's just not
possible
she told Joe Biden this on Twitter Joe
Biden had no choice but to agree with
her you're right Cynthia Biden wrote
back there is nothing decent about being
anti LGBTQ rights and that includes the
vice president people used to say that
Joe Biden was a decent guy too but in
the modern Democratic Party there are no
decent guys anymore there are only
people who are with the program and
apostates who deviate from it
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard suddenly is
in the latter category how did that
happen but he same measure Gabbard is a
staunch progressive but she does hold
heterodox opinions on foreign policy
instead of agreeing with Bill Krystal's
foreign policy she still believes what
many progressives used to believe she
wants to keep the u.s. out of pointless
foreign conflicts and instead focus on
domestic concerns and for having that
opinion
she's almost been expelled from her own
party watch they dismissed you is
sucking up to this dictator you're a bad
person is basically what they're saying
has anybody actually debated you on the
points that you're making
no no constantly I see again people from
both parties instead resorting to
name-calling or superficial attacks
because they refuse to engage on the
substance of this argument about why
they continue to push for and try to
wage these regime change wars ignoring
the disastrous consequences on the
people in those countries and the
American people so that's suddenly a
very controversial thing to say in the
modern democratic
already in place where there is no room
for dissent anywhere on any issue on
Wednesday for example a handful of
Democrats joined with Republicans to add
an amendment to a universal background
checks bill in the house that amendment
would require reporting a gun buyer to
ice if that buyer is an illegal alien a
group that is not allowed to buy guns in
the United States in a closed-door
meeting after the vote the Democrats who
join with Republicans on that were
reportedly denounced by party leadership
for their racism the party's new
ideological enforcer Alexandria Kazuya
Cortes warned the Democrats who helped
Republicans in any way would go on a
quote list and would have primary
challenges next time they ran so that's
what extremism looks like the enemy is a
hundred percent wrong and we are a
hundred percent right always they are
going to hell and were saved what is
happening here is a sin against God I
believe that Jesus said suffer the
little children unto me he did not say
let the children suffer a time in which
we celebrate the birth of Jesus Christ
thank God there wasn't a wall that
stopped him from seeking refuge in Egypt
thank God that wall wasn't there and
thank God there was an administration
like this and while we're doing the
Lord's work by ministering to the needs
of God's creation they are ignoring
those needs which is to dishonor the God
who made them mm-hmm we're doing God's
will were on God's side God loves us God
does not love the other side they're
sinners they're going against God's will
and in fact you know what
they could be Nazis this is the United
States of Germany the United States of
America isn't Nazi Germany bottom line
Donald Trump increasingly looks like
Hitler and Nazi Germany much like Hitler
took over the Nazi Party Trump has taken
over the Republican Party if you vote
for Trump then you the voter you not
Donald Trump or standing at the bar
border like Nazis though you hear you
here they are the tactics that have been
used through
the through history by the worst
purveyors of pure evil including slave
traders including Nazis including
terrorists so what you're looking at
that's not politics it's a cult nuance
is the enemy accommodation is a sin ask
too many questions or think too many
independent thoughts and you will be
denounced you'll wind up on commissar
Acacio cortezes list we reject this
completely it's totalitarian it's also
stupid and boring it's a replacement for
thought it's by the way destroying the
country as well we will always welcome
we just people we disagree with onto the
show we assume they are decent people
and by the way mostly they are decent
people we'll do our best to find common
ground with them and anyone else
whenever we can because why wouldn't we
and that's why you'll often see sincere
leftist on this show
treated with respect tulsi gabbard Glenn
Greenwald ro Khanna Michael Tracy many
others we disagree these people on a lot
of things but not on everything and
that's the point but most important of
all they are Americans just like us and
that matters most we need to remember
that